Webster's dictionary defines insanity as
reading the YouTube comments however I
do it every now and again yeah we try to
monitor what's going on we want to get a
sense of what you guys are thinking and
you know every now and again uh we get
some some real hate on something we said
sometimes you know like some of the
guests something you don't like what I
said mostly we actually get good stuff
which is actually incredibly nice
because if you guys are watching this on
youtube you know how the comment section
can be but generally people seem to dig
what we're doing and I thought we pull
out a couple comments from videos we've
done over the past couple weeks and talk
about it so up first we did a video two
weeks ago about how Elton John had said
that Jesus would love gay people all
right so here's a comment from sunny on
that video he said hey Dave just because
Jesus loves gays doesn't mean he
accepted your homosexual lifestyle /
behavior Jesus loves the sinner but
hates the sin sunny I'm gonna have to
beg to differ with you on this one um
first off I don't live my life by anyone
sort of rules but my own and I think
I've set some decent moral parameters
for my life and I don't think there's a
magical guy in the sky judging me as
Einstein said I don't think God's
playing dice with the universe and just
watching us and judging us I he's
probably got better things to do if he
exists at all so I'm really just not
concerned that Jesus is watching and
worrying about my sex life but thank you
for your concern and I hope you're
having some fun in bed ok we did a video
about how people don't trust mainstream
news which was actually one of my
favorite segments we've done recently
because yeah mainstream news is terrible
and that's why we do what we do here and
this person was referencing a video that
we showed a couple months back this is
on Andrea Mitchell reports on MSNBC
she's talking about the NSA with the
congresswoman and then watch what
happens I think at this point we should
seriously consider not geo not Kentucky
let me interrupt you congressman let me
interrupt you just for a moment we've
got some breaking news out of Miami
stand by if you will
right now in Miami Justin Bieber has
been arrested on a number of charges the
judges teach reading the charges
including resisting arrest and driving
under the influence he's appearing now
before the judge for his bond hearing
let's watch Soufan 211 commented don't
forget about interrupting a serious
discussion with someone for breaking
news about justin bieber and kris jenner
because lord knows we care about them so
that obviously is the clip that he was
referencing yes this is exactly what is
wrong with mainstream news you know the
beauty about what we do on YouTube uh
and not just not just us and not just
for use but you select what you want to
watch so we put up we try to put up
seven videos per week and guess what if
you don't like the topic you don't click
it and that's it and it's as simple as
that but with these mainstream news
organizations they're selecting what
they're giving you and you don't know
when it's coming up and because of that
they can give you for example CNN's
three months of plane coverage which got
no resolution and they were speculating
the entire time or MSNBC talking about
the NSA the NSA and breaking into justin
bieber going to court and it I've talked
about this a lot the minutia of court
details is is beyond ridiculous or
forget even Bieber in this but whenever
they show some court thing about you
know a murder some horrific thing when
they're just showing you what's
happening in the court there's nothing
more dribble asst than that and then of
course you throw in Bieber so the
problem is that the mainstream media is
driven by ratings now of course we want
you guys to click this every week I want
our clicks to go up in our views to go
up and they are going up we've doubled
since September it's all working uh and
that's the beauty of YouTube and that's
the beauty of why people are coming to
uh online news sources instead of
mainstream news so it's pretty great we
did video a couple weeks ago on what is
a spore no sexual uh the guy who coined
the phrase metrosexual says that
metrosexuals are passed a house porno
sexuals are these guys straight guys who
are obsessed with their bodies and
muscles and tattoos and it's not just
about looking good in the fancy clothes
anymore inserted the david beckham's
it's more of a combination of porn and
you know selfie image so Booster Gold
had this to say in what world was it
gay men who had good physiques I know
plenty of fat stick-thin an average body
gay guys and I know plenty of amazingly
in shape heterosexual men both athletes
and just guys who spent a lot of time at
the gym now he's referencing a comment I
I joked about how sport a sexual are
straight guys just becoming gay now I
live in West Hollywood which is you know
like a gay Mecca and they're just guys
with huge muscles walking around all the
time and they're always going to the gym
no matter what time it is they're always
going to the gym never see them leave
the gym but they're going to the gym and
they have huge muscles and little dogs
your bicep should not be bigger than
your ops ops uh um and uh so yes there
are all kinds of gay guys I don't have a
perfectly tight six-pack there i said it
let the judgment begin uh and of course
there are there are perfectly in shape
straight guys in there out of shape gay
guys and there's everything in between
that's what makes the world go around
but yes but every community does have a
different thing about body image and I
think the gay community is different
issue about body image than the straight
community but some of its all kind of
blending and that's progress when we all
realize that ultimately were really just
the same and finally we did a video a
couple weeks ago on conspiracy theories
and we were quoting some info that a
tremendous amount of Americans actually
do believe in conspiracy theories and we
got a comment here from Daniel bloom he
said I like to read into conspiracy
theories but without a hundred percent
evidence I won't say they're a hundred
percent true like Bill Maher says in
religious what I'm presenting is doubt
when I read and see how much of our
federal government has lied to us and
usually so they can get more money in
their pockets and then to see how much
and how many people have benefited from
the war in Iraq you can't help but
wonder yeah uh I often quote Bill Maher
who's a major influence of mine uh you
know one of the comments that I made in
that video was Carl Sagan who said
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence and part of the
thing with conspiracy theories is their
conspiracy theories because they can't
be proven so you have a lot of evidence
that you know the government was in on
it or Lyndon Johnson was in on it on the
JFK assassination or you can believe in
aliens or whatever it is you could say
you saw it what you think was an alien
but unless you have evidence then
obviously
you know not that many people are gonna
believe it uh so i kinda believe some of
these things i don't think we're
probably not alone in the universe I
think the day I getting a problem
probably did happen uh but ultimately
you need evidence for all these things
and but that you know thinking about all
these things and speculating what what
the truth really is it worked for X
Files for many years and and it's fun
it's fun to think about and it's fun to
talk about it also makes you feel not
that alone because yeah we're not
getting just the the truth all the time
from whatever source you're watching
you're not getting the truth from all
the time so thinking about these things
and talking about them because it
validates your crazy thoughts too is a
lot of fun and anyway speaking of fun I
think this was totally fun and we will
do this again we'll keep watching the
YouTube comments and you know so you
keep liking and sharing and doing all
that stuff and that's it thanks for
watching